so every once in a while an animated on
a show will post their own production
material for a show they've worked on
right so and yeah this one from a recent
One Piece episode is an absolute treat
to look at this one was actually posted
by a one-piece account themselves and
features a full 30 second cut from
foreign animators I'm gonna butcher
their names so forgive me ole Loken
Jeremy Pires and Jocelyn Charles the
latter of whom is the guy who did this
brain breaking Pepe animation it is
always such a blast to see these
animations raw and the fluidity of
motion here in particular is spectacular
not just in the action but in tertiary
elements like her hair effects work and
characteractic this cut in particular is
almost reminiscent of early Max flesh or
Western animation it's not only
fascinating to go through frame by frame
but also a very stacked reminder of how
insane 2D animation is even today every
single frame of this was hand-drawn
meticulously by a real person it just
boggles the mind